décidée soldes et la d'edo henry joint
sur son île aux chansons nouveau rythme
le pêcheur de meaux a pris le large
pendant un an autour du monde et des
gens de la planète
hélas à mort dont
comme ça de vrai
pourquoi toujours l'espoir à la pêche
ouais dans tous les métiers dans des
grandes gueules ce que je ferai quelque
chose
l'aspiration
une phrase la musique une tranche de vie
entre deux tranches d'oublier le temps à
effacer notre as un malentendu
seeded un aller sans retour
d'amour a perdu la face l'île de ré
c'est la terre d'écriture d'une partie
de ce nouvel album paradis payen le
grand jacques 98 haddock de la
géographie sereine 20 ans de chansons
higelin tout un atlas avec ses mélodies
en bande x et ses sommets comprend moins
bien mais j'étais cette clique hayon qu
aux anges l'adresse car ben là près du
portrait qui ont taillé ya plus personne
pourquoi pas c'est l'habitude jamais
normal un musicien devant pour faire
écran et je me chauffe petit à petit
derrière je me planque derrière le
bassiste bat of tanks là j'ai
l'impression d'être à nu et ça m'est
venu même l'idée que je pourrais le
faire un jour et dans le plus simple
appareil au paradis et note higelin ou
la belle vie elle monte en chanter
arrêté mon comme cendrillon
soleil et à lui donner